la situación está muy tensa muy delicada
nosotros estamos recibiendo denuncias
denuncias hemos recibido denuncias sobre
asesinatos es decir homicidios en varias
varios de los departamentos de colombia
y también sobre casos de personas
heridas y heridos graves estamos en un
proceso de verificación de esta
información pero todo indica que hay
evidentes casos de exceso en el uso de
la fuerza por parte de la policía un
aspecto que es muy delicado es el uso
del ejército para tareas de orden
público creo que el gobierno del
presidente iván duque está jugando con
fuego y está corriendo un alto riesgo
porque los soldados los militares están
preparados para la guerra para el
conflicto armado más aún o especialmente
los soldados colombianos
y no para tareas de orden público creo
que es una una irresponsabilidad del
gobierno usar a soldados en contextos
urbanos de control de orden público